- affinity and beyond no live long and
prosper how you're gonna teach me you
have all your fingers together I do and
then you just go like this stay together
put them all together okay and then just
I do this I go there that's that's the
shocker
hi I'm Ashley Nicole black and today
we're talking about Nichelle Nichols
so it's 1964 and Nichelle Nichols guest
stars on an episode of a show called the
lieutenant that's run by Gene
Roddenberry and Gene Roddenberry was
like you're amazing you're so beautiful
do you want to be on this new show
called Star Trek here's my plan
it's gonna be super utopian and black
ladies can be bosses this is actually a
really big deal
so Nichelle Nichols is like that sounds
chill as hell so let's do that show so
they start filming Star Trek and
Nichelle Nichols plays lieutenant O'Hara
who's the communications officer so
she's like captain I have something to
communicate with you
she has nails that are way too long for
space but also a show Nichols doesn't
actually watch the show because back
then TV came on at a certain time and
she was at work during that time so at
the end of the first season she's like
Star Trek is cool whatever I don't know
if anybody watches it but my dream is to
be on Broadway I'm gonna say I want to
dance and she goes to Gene Roddenberry
she's like hey I'm gonna go Broadway so
I'm done trekking I'm done so he tells
her like please just like take the
weekend to think about it and she's like
whatever bitch
fine so that weekend Nichelle Nichols
goes to an N double ACP fundraiser and
one of the organizers comes up to her
and is like hey there's a guy here and
he's your biggest fan and he really
wants to meet you and she's like okay
cool whatever
bring on the nerd and she sees her fan
and he's like your show is
the only show that I allow my three
little children to stab and watch
we love Star Trek it's so good it's just
like excuse me are you Martin Luther
King and he's like yes I am Martin
Luther King and I'm a Trekkie and she's
like but it's real Martin Luther King
loves Star Trek and he's like you were
the only black woman on television who
doesn't play a servant you're the only
person out there providing hope it's a
black people that there's a future where
baby thing won't be seen as less than
and they'll be seen as equals and she's
like wow that's great except for I'm
leaving I quit Star Trek this week I'm
so sorry
and he's like no you can't quit do you
realize you're the first black woman
who's black woman he wasn't drunk when
he said it it's okay I was drunk but
Martin Luther King was like you leave
there's one image that children have of
a black woman as an equal will just
disappear from television and she's like
that's a lot that's like a lot that's a
lot on my shoulders can you chill and
he's like no I'm Martin Luther King I'm
no chill she's like okay I'll think
about it stay tuned for more drunk
history do you know how the first
interracial kiss on television happened
so Nichelle Nichols goes into Gene
Roddenberry's office it's just like gene
I met Martin Luther King this weekend
and he really likes her and he's
like oh my god someone understands what
I'm trying to do here she's like oh my
god shut that bust at the point the
point is this show is going to advance
racial equality I'll stay on your show
so you know they're filming Star Wars
it's great is that true
so they're doing Star Trek it's great
people love it at some point Gene
Roddenberry's like I know we're gonna
push the envelope we're gonna have the
first interracial kiss and William
Shatner is like hell yes and Nichelle
Nichols is like whatever fine but the
network came down and was like whoa hold
on we can't have an interracial kiss on
TV so William Shatner convinces them
let's shoot it both ways
we'll shoot it with the kiss first and
then we'll shoot it without and you can
decide what you want to do in editing so
they shoot the scene with the kiss and
then he's like you know what I have a
note let's try it again soon one more
time and they shoot it over and over and
over again and they're like William
enough kissing okay we only have time to
shoot this one more time he's like okay
let's just do one without the kiss so it
isn't until the next day that they watch
the scene and see that William Shatner
crosses his eyes to the camera and
they're like what the is is really
happening and won't shatter was like I
guess we either have to air this
interracial kiss or not have a seat and
that is how the first interracial kiss
gets on television Wow and then in 1969
America Lancel
and every America is like oh my god we
light on the moon it's amazing and a
show was like hold up
that's all white dudes what the right so
she gives this big speech and she's like
NASA get your together
can you please recruit someone to be an
astronaut who's not a white dude and
NASA's like okay cool but like can you
do it cuz we don't know anybody who's
got a white dude
so Nichelle Nichols was like uh black
ladies have to do everything she travels
around the country and she recruits
people to be in NASA she's like hey by
people Asians
lady people join go space and they're
like okay cool and she recruited Sally
right and then she recruits Colonel
Buford he's the first like dude to be at
NASA and then she recruited in a Jemison
and she's like hey you should apply for
NASA and May Jemison is like oh my god
you were on Star Trek I love you but
she's like pay attention so Nichelle
Nichols was like the first black lady to
go to space for fake and she recruited
the first black lady to go to space for
real she literally integrated space
everybody who's really good at math or
whatever you have to be good at to be
good at NASA can do whatever they want
to do but we still need to prosper if
we're gonna live long yeah this America
right now it's trying so hard
[Music]